to preface this i
the last two years have obviously been
horrible and yeah especially in those
first six months i truly
leaned on you
for emotional and mental well-being uh
for you guys to continue through
everything and keep putting out just joy
was such oh that's so nice of you to say
to my happiness so
thank you i have uh i've made something
for you
oh my god that's fantastic wow
look at that it's a sand sculpture of
the in like a 3d freeze of logo of this
podcast
it's so cool it's gorgeous and you know
what for a second i'm like that's my
tombstone
yeah that's it i mean whenever my time
comes and i hope it's not for a while
that's it it's i want it to be
a couple of months at most for that to
last so i don't want to make any
suggestions no
look i know what dean's gonna do he's
gonna he's gonna hose it down with some
epoxy so it lasts
at least six months and that's about as
long as people are gonna be visiting my
grave
and then they're gonna quickly move on
well dean
you know what i'm it's uh heartening uh
and to to know that you've been out
there listening and uh i know it's been
a tough time for a lot of people but um
you will persevere you will thrive uh
and
you deserve all good things and thanks
for being so creative and so nice and
onward and upward things are getting a
lot better now dean so and thank you for
making that sculpture that's cool yeah
of course there's least i could do is
really an honor to be here and meet you
guys definitely hey honor honor to meet
you dean really cool you're a good man
you're living the dream dean you're
living the doing you are oh dean machine
dream i'm sorry about matt there's only
so much we can do with him
i'm not sorry about me i'm getting a
ventriloquist dummy soon
[Laughter]
you'll miss me when i'm gone